hear that all right vegas is getting
spicy okay revazo latin and music
festival is taking over september 10th
and 11th and the festival organizer vic
juarez is here with all the details vic
do you know the song can you hear it
exactly exactly welcome to las vegas now
where are you calling from
dallas texas thank you so much so
excited to kick things off in las vegas
i cannot wait till you get here and
bring all this culture to our city now
this is the first ever rambasa festival
so just explain like how are you feeling
now that the vision has come to life and
it's happening
we're so excited about the opportunity
to kick things off and obviously in the
epicenter of you know the just the
entertainment center of the world so las
vegas so we're super excited to be in
groupasso on september 10th at the
downtown las vegas event center we have
you can see you have a we have an
amazing lineup we have maluma we have
prince royce
we have the queen evie queen so we're
covering all bases as it turns out as it
relates to music amazing and we're
seeing photos of the vibes right now now
what inspired you guys to bring this
event together and to bring it to las
vegas
well so obviously uh you know hispanic
heritage month is obviously why we're
doing this and what is what we're
celebrating but you know this
you know the festival world is it's it's
kind of full right now and we thought
that you know the latin audience kind of
deserved uh you know a great show with a
great lineup and an affordable price and
obviously with you know with partners
like like and heiser bush and we're able
to provide such a beautiful show with
with this amazing lineup with first in
class production and like again at such
an affordable price that you wouldn't be
able to find any at this pricing with
just one artist much the less
plus seven and more so excited and the
rise of latin music is just amazing to
see so what how does the festival work
though what's the process like do you is
it one location or is it going across
las vegas how does it work
so we're so until the the festival is
going to be september 10th at downtown
las vegas event center there will be
surprises obviously like any latin party
we have a pre-party we'll have an after
party
we'll announce those when we're ready
but you know our focus right now and the
thing that we want to just blow up out
of the water it's going to be a rambasso
september 10th downtown las vegas event
center all right well we will be there
thank you so much vic for joining us you
can get tickets at rambassofest.com
right
fest.com and we we can't wait to see
everyone there i promise we're going to
deliver on a great show thank you so
much and this is just your one so we are
excited to have you guys here in vegas
we're honored more to come thank you so
much all right big see you later ramasa
latin and music festival taking over las
vegas september 10th and 11 tickets on
sale now at rumba
rumbazzofest.com jc i'll send it over to
you for my